I recently read an article,
which suggested that the periodic table that we love,
we see everywhere on the wall of your classroom,
on your t-shirt on your mouse mat,
perhaps even your books or shorts may be wrong.
And that was a huge surprise for me.
So let me try and explain to you what the problem is here.
We've got the so-called ultra long periodic table,
where in these two bottom rows,
you have the elements listed in numerical order of their atomic numbers.
So they go here, bear in 56 length and then 57 serum,
58 and so on.
And the one below you have radium 88 actinium
89. And so on this sort of shape doesn't fit very well.
Well on to walls, into books,
onto mouse mats, onto boxer shorts. Normally, yeah,
you have one like this where this block of elements has
been snipped out and put underneath.
And so lanthanum and actinium Aronda scandium and
itching room. Lanthanum has a little red spot on top of it,
which means this lot had been left out. And if you look at the numbers,
they jump from 57 to 72,
and then the road below the two stars for this row.
And you jumped from element 89 to run the food in 104.
If we look at this rather unusual period it
table,
which was given to me by one of our YouTube fans,
what you can see is that there are two spaces here.
And instead of being 14 elements there,
15 elements underneath and lanthanum,
and actinium instead of being there been put there. Now,
let me explain what the paper was that I looked at the paper,
which has a slightly and promising title measurement.
The first ionization potential of Lauryn SIM element
103 Lorenz SIM is this element at the end,
here is experimentally at triumph.
Lorenzo Liam is an so-called super heavy element.
You have to synthesize it in accelerators.
It has a very short half-life. The isotope,
they were measuring has a half-life of 27 seconds.
That means after 27 seconds,
half your Lorenz SIM is gone and they were doing measurements on individual
atoms, and they were measuring a slightly obscure quantity.
The so-called first organization, energy,
which is the amount of energy she required to remove the first electron.
And what they discovered was SIM has a very low first-time
nitration energy and quite pleasingly.
You can see that the value that has been measured
4.96 electron volts is almost identical
to what's has been calculated by theory,
but what's this got to do with the periodic table.
What they're suggesting is that lutetium and Lorenzo Liam
should be sitting under the standard Monotreme that is the
big break in the periodic table should actually come there
rather than there. So if you have the short form,
you would have the dot over radium. You'd go down to that.
Technium you'd go along to new billion and then up here to Lorenz. Yeah.
So what they're saying is that the properties of Lorencia
are much more like instrument scandium then
the properties of lanthanum and a 10 year Mar their argument
is that the ionization energies of Lorenz SIM
fit much better with those of this group.
Then the analyzations of lanthanum Tanium do so,
what they are saying, bluntly is lanthanum,
and actinium probably shouldn't be in group three lutetium and
Lorenz Siham should be in group three because the way the periodic
table is structured,
you would expect there to be elements at the bottom of group three.
Now, of course,
this is partly theoretical because there are only a few atoms
of Lorenz SIM have been made.
So it's not as if you are going to start using Lorenz SIM for making
catalysts or whatever, but on the other hand,
it is quite important for understanding of the structure of the periodic table.
My memory of chemistry from school is rather hazy, but I seem to recall,
we were told which elements went in,
which group depended on how many electrons were available for
business in that outer valence shell. Yeah.
And we know how many electrons that are in the outer show,
surely for all of these elements. So it doesn't dictate it.
Now you're telling me it's done experimentally by ionization energies.
In this road here from scandium to zinc and all the others
you're filling up the so-called DS shells of the electrons.
And down here, you're filling up the so-called F shell.
What this argument boils down to is that
they're saying that perhaps rather than putting in one DL electron,
and then filling up the F shell, you put in, fill up the FCL.
And then at the D electron,
it could be that the break is different in the two rows.
It could be that lanthanum is here and
Lorenz is there. And that the break doesn't happen in the same place,
in the two rows.
That will be a real mess for the people who draw periodic tables.
But what we're interested in is what nature is like,
not how easy it is to draw it.
So, um,
we're braving the elements Brady to repeat the experiment that we did quite some
time ago, heat.
That till it's warm and put it in the chlorine declawing and oxidize it to
include.